So yesterday was the first day of the second
impeachment trial of Donald Trump, and we we had
some hints that it was going to be an absolutely
embarrassing, pathetic attempt at an impeachment
defense. And one of the reasons we thought that
was that multiple times in legal briefs submitted
by Donald Trump's various beleaguered legal teams,
they misspelled the United States. They misspelled
it as United States. And that probably was not
the auspicious start that they were going for.
And it ended up being an absolutely farcical
presentation. Yesterday was a day it it was day
one. But at the same time, it wasn't in the sense
that the topic of four hours of debate yesterday,
four hours of presentations, rather, there was
not debate among senators. The topic, the reason
for yesterday's four hours of presentations was
merely to convince the Senate one way or the other
about whether the Senate has the authority and
the jurisdiction to hold an impeachment trial of
a president that is no longer president, a former
president, a past president, and why you would
have the Senate decide about constitutionality? I
don't know. And many legal scholars were not clear
as to why the Senate was being put in the position
of having to decide whether it was constitutional.
But that's what yesterday was about.
The Senate decided not by a huge margin, 56 to 44,
that, yes, the Senate can hold an
impeachment trial of a president
who is no longer the sitting president.
Democratic Congressman Jamie Raskin opened the
proceedings as one of the impeachment managers.
He spoke really well included in his presentation,
an absolutely devastating video of what happened
on January 6th, cutting back and forth from what
Donald Trump was saying and what was happening
at the Capitol. And then it was the turn.
It was Trump's lawyers turn and a guy named Bruce
Castor spoke. We covered it live and he droned on
for about 50 minutes about nothing germane to
the impeachment of Donald Trump. Now, you might
say that must be an exaggeration, David. It must
have been somewhat related to the impeachment.
I couldn't figure out how our live audience of
about 40000 people couldn't figure out how it
was related to Bruce Castor going on about
British law before the Revolutionary War,
his personal relationships with
some of the senators in the chamber.
It's absurd. It's unintelligible. Let's
look at some clips here as Bruce Castor,
starting with his own childhood and the
political preferences of his parents.
When I was growing up in suburban Philadelphia,
my parents were big fans of Senator Everett
Dirksen from Illinois. And Senator Dirksen
recorded a series of lectures that
my parents had on a record. And
we still know what records are right on the
thing you put the needle down on and we play.
So that type of stuff went on about ten minutes.
Then Kastor started talking about how cool
and great senators are as individuals
and how senators tend to like the
states that they are from their families.
They love the states that they represent,
there isn't a member in this room who has not
used the term I represent the great state of
fill in the blank. Why? Because they're all great.
Yeah, but you think yours is greater than others?
Because these are your people. These are the
people that sent you here to do their work.
It genuinely seemed like maybe Bruce Castor
prepared for some other trial about something
different than the impeachment of Donald
Trump, because none of what he said made
any sense. It became like an open mic night,
which then continued with more discussion of
what it means to be in the United States
Senate as far as Bruce Castor was concerned.
So senators are Patriots, senators are family men
and women. They're fierce advocates for the great
state in which they represent and somewhere far
down that list of attributes, way below Patriot
and way below love of family and country and way
below fierce advocates for their states far down.
At least that's what I thought anyway, and I still
think that somewhere far down that list, senators
have some obligation to be partizans.
If you're wondering
what on earth he's talking about, did you miss
something? We were all wondering that yesterday.
It made no sense whatsoever. I had no idea
what this guy was talking about. And indeed,
Donald Trump was not happy. We'll talk more
about this later in the show. But here's a report
from CNN about just how displeased and rightly
so, how displeased Trump was with this.
Not think that was a strong opening argument.
And then to have the first attorney admit that he
believed the House impeachment managers did a good
job. Also, it was confusing to a lot of people on
the president's team. But, yes, Trump was not
happy with that performance. He was borderline
screaming over what was going on as
he was talking to people about this.
It wasn't just Donald Trump who was
not pleased with what Bruce Castor did.
Fox News host Sean Hannity himself couldn't
even resist mentioning multiple times that
it was a meandering presentation that Hannity
didn't really understand. Here he is saying
it to Republican Senator Ted Cruz.
I thought it was a little bit of a
weak start. I'm not being critical. Just
a little lackluster. Meandering to me.
Needed a little more focus, needs
focus meandering. Quite an quite an
understatement if you saw the 50 minutes
of atrocities from Bruce Castor there.
And then this is even better when interviewing
Donald Trump's other lawyer, David shown again,
Hannity says he he didn't really understand that.
First part of your argument. I love your passion.
I thought it started a little meandering. It
was sort of like a lot of free associating in
the beginning. And I'm not I'm not attacking
your partner. I don't I don't know him at all.
So even Sean Hannity has to concede in his own
words, in his own understated way. This was
absolutely off the wall, bonkers. And it was also
even some Republican senators that noticed this.
Here is Republican Senator Bill Cassidy saying,
I didn't know what he was talking about. I if I
just have to vote based on what I see there, they
didn't make the case Trump's lawyers for anything.
I listened to it. It speaks for
itself. It was disorganized, random,
had nothing. They talked about many things,
but they didn't talk about the issue at hand.
And so if if you if I were an impartial juror
and I'm trying to make a decision based upon
the facts as presented on this issue, then
the House managers did a much better job.
It was really like a verbal inkblot free
association, a kind of senatorial Rorschach test
of sorts. What do you here's 50 minutes of
words, mostly words. What do you make? What
can you make out of them? What do you see in
there? And even many Republican senators saying,
I can't see anything in there. That doesn't
make any sense as far as I was watching it.
Ah, with our audience on the livestream yesterday,
I was saying, does Trump fire this guy by today?
As of yet, he has not been fired. But later on
in the show, we are going to have a report about
what exactly was going on with Donald
Trump, including apparently screaming
as Bruce Castor was making his
presentation. We'll see if day two
goes any better for Trump's legal team.
That's coming up a little bit later today.